The independence we have
is incredibly important to us. We do
n't have to meet any of the rules set by
financiers. We can decide for ourselves
where we grow, how we grow, how
fast we grow, what we buy or
don't buy. This entrepreneurial
independence is
worth a lot to me  and I can't
imagine it any other way. Those who
thought that even after Corona, people would only
buy online, they were
wrong and I could see that
during the Corona period, of course, the
online business benefited enormously because
the shops were closed, no question
But after that there were also declines again.
I think the Deichmann concept can be
described relatively well with the best
price-performance ratio in
the low price range and I think
brands are an incredibly important
part of our strategy because you
can use brands to communicate quality very well to the customer
Welcome to the OMR podcast
home game for me in Essen with
one of the most exciting films
ever in Germany, but it's
based in Essen, with whom I basically grew up, and it's
also called the same as my
two guests
today. Welcome, um, I'm here with the
Deichmanns  hello Philipp, it's nice that you
're here, hello Philipp, it's nice that you're here,
tell me a little bit about the
history of Deichmann, I know it
quite well, but it's already over
100 years old, no, not far from here,
kilometers away, maybe my
grandfather is 19
opened his first Schumacher store
and
it then became a retail chain in the Ruhr area and then
throughout Germany then in Europe and
now all over the world and as
is always the case, I think the first
generation to set up a store
opened it was here  For the
buddies, i.e. for the
miners or the mining workers,
shoes were simply made cheaply
so that everyone could afford them,
good quality, but that was
n't a really big start-up in
the sense that they were now trying to create
a medium-sized or
large company  to build it was
your father's generation, so to speak,
who started it, really,
my grandfather was a Schumacher and he
just wanted to feed his family and
he basically already
invented our recipe for success because his
customers were his friends, acquaintances,
neighbors and  But these were people who
worked here primarily in the mines and in the steelworks
and they didn't earn a lot of money back then,
but he wanted to
offer these customers good quality,
decent shoes but at a
reasonable price and that became
the recipe for success  for us to this day that
is our special strength great shoes
good quality interesting fashion great
brands but always at a good price
and
my grandfather died relatively early in
1940 then my
grandmother first took over the business and
my father joined him after the war
first studied medicine and
also worked as a doctor, but he
opened several sales outlets during his studies and at some point he
felt that he had to
decide to remain a doctor again or to
really
continue and develop this company again and
he decided on that  company
decided and yes then
the big branching really began.
We started going abroad in the early 70s. In
1973 my father
bought his first chain in Switzerland, in Fügenbach
and then things continued in the 80s. In
84 a small one came along  Chain in the
USA which is now a large chain
85 in the Netherlands then 89 again
in Switzerland
and yes
I use 89 joined the company
shortly before the fall of the Berlin Wall and then there was another
enormous growth spurt
due to the opening in the East  And yes,
above all, I took a new
path to growth, so to speak. I
no longer bought companies
but started organic growth.
The first country back then was
Austria in 1992. We started there from
scratch and that turned out to be
a really good vehicle for
growth  You don't have to look for companies,
you don't have to
laboriously integrate them, you can
basically choose the locations
you want to have, you can choose the employees
you want to have, the turnover the
company made, i.e. the group
when you came or were there  A
billion-dollar company but
I actually ca
n't say the exact number then a billion German marks
would have been millions of euros better,
but that means that's still
a significant amount of growth
or the greatest growth to this 8
That's right,
I joined the company in 1989
and took over as chairman in 1999 and
in fact, I think there was a
disdain for sales and yes,
a few changes came with me  The
first was this organic
growth, for example, I have
certainly focused a lot more on young fashion
in the range, but
I have also introduced more and more brands. We
now have a huge business with
our sports brands Adidas Nike Puma,
but we have also bought brands and licenses
and could do that  European license from
many, for example, we have the
license from Esprit, we
bought the Bench brand for shoes. Above all,
the purchase of the
Elephant brand in
2005 was very important. Elephant is the epitome of
quality for children's shoes and we
had the brand with everything back then  the
technology, the strip park and so on,
some core employees also took over and
continued the Elephant brand at the same level of quality as before, but simply at much
cheaper costs and were therefore able to
attract additional customers to us. We were also able to determine this with
market research at the time.
We have our customer base  really
significantly expanded because Elephant
simply had a customer base that
was used to quality and people
then came to us and of course
also bought other shoes and
we continued along the path
and today we are in the process of expanding even further as far
as this
brand portfolio is concerned  It turned out
to be very important. We verticalized
our procurement from the end of the 90s.
That was perhaps the
most important step, something that started much earlier with the
textile H&M in the text.
We basically
took over part of the value chain ourselves, traditionally something in the
shoe trade  It was common for you to buy your shoes
from
manufacturers who
had developed and manufactured these shoes and
if you wanted to buy them cheaply
you bought them in the Far East from large
traders. These traders
developed collections for many customers and then
of course resold the goods at a markup
and we  We
took on this part of the value creation ourselves, which
means we hired our own designers, our
own canvas pictures, our own
technicians and then we basically developed our collection where
good quality can be produced cheaply
and
as a result we once again incurred enormous costs -
the factories don't belong to us
but they work  on a large scale
for us here, especially in China,
I would also like to say something else
and in this way we
simply saved a lot of costs, were able to
become cheaper, were able to
become faster and were able to become more independent, so
we were not dependent on
anyone else  Manufacturers
were not able to offer fashion themes or special brands, but we were able to
organize it ourselves.
We also took over the entire logistics ourselves. We consolidated the goods there in the
Far East, negotiated our own
freight rates and were able to save
costs again thanks to the estuary effect.
That was for  The company is very, very
important, the verticalization and
maybe I can still say that what
we did in the 90s
was that we increasingly
went into television advertising, which was
not so common for the shoe trade at that time,
but above
all with testimonials and only with
German tests are then with
well-known international ones. I can
remember working with
Hally Berry, who was a lot of fun,
a great person, Crawford
worked for us,
the sometimes well-known music in the
Pussycat Dolls, the sugarbabes at the end,
Rita Ora,
today Leni Klum for  Error right, so
that has definitely
really changed our image again, we have
become more of a lifestyle brand,
of course we have low prices but
we don't just stand for low prices,
we understand fashion, we also stand for
a certain trend and we stand by it
also for quality now and for
a lot of brands and yes, it's all
connected to this effort,
working in the company as fourth
generation for almost exactly three years, I
studied the game world very well,
bachelor's master's degree in the uh then I have another
three months of social time  I
was taken to the children's home in the Antennas in
Peru and after that I had an easier cultural
change like 90% of my fellow students who
went to BCG for advice. I was
in the Berlin office for exactly two years until mid-2019
and then I had about a
year before I joined the company, so to speak  I
wanted to go and I geared it
a little more towards the digital
world. I
was only at Headline for a few months
when Check Capital was
still doing events at the time and then another
six months at Tarik.
You could say that in particular  Let them
let me in anyway and we are still
very friendly,
so to speak, today's introduction so the
business member brought the time
I saw that you can also
say that so we
met there everything in the barking Alex
Berlin had exactly that, we say  As
part of the IPO, he decided
to move a little closer to his wife's homeland. She is originally
from Düsseldorf and then
we started talking. My father
asked me, don't you know him? I said yes,
I know if you want to hire me
He's definitely a very, very
good one and now he's been around for a while now,
as is this possible, so many
generations, so I mean, your
father has obviously already made a lot of
progress here, and now there's also
a special strategy to
develop this further, so to speak
or what was it like for you?
I mean, you really had a
significant influence on the structure. In the
end, it's lucky that you have it in the family
or can you prepare yourself with it
or do you try to keep the collection in
reserve? Yes, of
course there is  Factors
that help, so my father always registered the company
in the family
and you just got a lot out
of it and that's why I was able to
identify with it very early on, although the special thing was
that my father was not only a
successful entrepreneur but also  He
did an incredible amount of good, he
founded a foundation in the past and was
able to implement great social projects in various places around the world and I thought this
combination was great and
I could identify with that and
I actually wanted to emulate that and that's
why it was for me  It was clear relatively early on, yes,
I would actually like to
follow in his footsteps and yes, then
you just take a lot with you and absorb a lot and
I also studied the world
but also did a bit of humanities on the side because
that interested me more, but also
philosophy, history, theology
Then business administration was clear
and then I went to work in the company. I did
n't have much time because my
father was a bit older and
he wanted to have me with him very quickly,
so straight from the university
to the office and then just
see where I could get started  There are tasks and where you
can move things forward. My father was
really a great
partner in the sense that he
gave freedom, so he was actually
able to hand over responsibility and
I seem to have done that quite well.
In the beginning there was more and
more marketing  also
purchasing and then the foreign business
and in the way you
grew more and more into the task and at
some point in 1999 I went to my father
and said and that's it,
I can say that it's not
new  I just said, dear
father, I somehow have the feeling
that I'm now pretty much controlling the company
and running it operationally,
don't we want to call it that and then
he thought about it and of course
for the founder it's
essentially alcohol  Rector then
you can't do it that easily but the next day
I became the chairman of the
management and then the
change in management was almost official and there are
always two sides to it, if
it works well it really involves the
father who
is willing to hand over responsibility  Then you also manage to take a
step back and that's not
easy with people who really had almost
zero with my father, which wasn't zero
but it was very small but
normal, then
built up something big and then said no, now
I'm giving up, that's not psychological
He simply did a great job because
the company was always recommended
to him. It was important to him that
the company was doing well, so he then saw
that I was probably doing it quite well and was
doing things differently and pushing forward. He had
already realized that, that's now  right
and even if it
wasn't always easy personally, he took the
step and yes, as I said, I
enjoyed it. I was able to
move things forward. I was able to move things forward.
I have the feeling that there are a few recipes
that are still valid today, for example
these  The company is 100% family-owned, but I
wouldn't think so, so
big, I think 45,000 employees,
employee 8, I have a turnover, we've
already said that we've made a lot of acquisitions,
but that's what you do to inform everything. It
's also a mantra, but it
has to be everywhere  Generation stay like that, it
should be that way, yes, the
independence we have is
incredibly important to us. We do
n't have to meet any of the rules set by donors.
We can decide for ourselves
[music]
what we buy or don't buy. This
entrepreneurial independence is what
I like  It's worth an incredible amount and
I can't imagine it any other way,
there were never any considerations about
changing it and that's
a bit like family law, you can
say 100%, so I can describe it the same way,
we want to maintain this independence and  also
this spirit that we
are in a family business and the
people who work with us
really notice that because we
are also very present as a company, so
I think that is something that is very, very
important to both of us at the moment, not
even in the last few years  sometimes I was a
bit worried about the
business model, so when I'm
still building, I've read currently that I have
200 branches that I wanted to open somehow this
year and you think, okay, everything
is going on the Internet and then there are
endless building control branches, you already have
10,000 of how many  Years ago
you have exactly we have in the summer,
it's already
further, so to speak, why do you have this blatant
belief that, for example, this will be a success
in the future
because the business simply speaks for it,
um those who thought that even after
Corona would only buy on the Internet,
they have  I was wrong and was
able to observe that.
During the corona period,
the online business obviously benefited enormously
because the shops were closed, no
question, but after that there were
declines again and we experienced that.
We also made a certain leap online
in the corona period.  But as
with everyone, online business
fell slightly again last year and
our stores
came back enormously. Last year we
made sales that were higher than in 2019
and I really had the feeling
and that's actually what I had
I always had an idea that when
people were locked up for so long
and were no longer able to have many social contacts,
then they
also felt the need
to go to the shops again, to touch real things, to
talk to people, and shopping is
also a really nice experience
That's somehow fulfilling in a
psychosocial sense and that you
just sit on the couch
when you go shopping, that doesn't meet all the
needs that people have, but the
question is, regardless of
Corona, you have it in your own hands
because if you yourself are dependent on
inner cities, so to speak, and
people's lives are in inner cities and we're
not just talking about Hamburg.
Berlin has 4,000 branches, then it's
clear that they are also in some
smaller cities or
towns, they have to be because  There aren't that many
greetings, um, and
then you're no longer in a
position to help
develop the trends yourself, so to speak, but
you're also dependent on such a huge amount of development
and then
maybe they just mean there are no
others  and then in the
end I'm no longer worried about that now I
think what's still a very positive factor for us at the moment
is that
we
're often in situations, especially in Germany,
where we haven't lost that much traffic
in recent times
For example, you can imagine that there are more than 600 shops in
a retail park like this, there
is a large
parking lot in the middle, there is
a Kik in Aldi next to it, there is a Lidl in the Lidl and
we and we, especially
the grocery store, still see this very much  is
strongly based in the stationary store
and that means as soon as the families have
driven into this parking lot
they go to Aldi first, then
they maybe go to DM again and if
they have children with them, you know, if in
doubt, I have the
little ones with me right now  I'm going to go
to Deichmann again for a short time, try
on my children's shoes and then I can complete the whole thing
in one purchase,
so to speak, so it's not so dependent on
these classic
inner-city bulldozing miles, but it
's more like
that  What's interesting is that
even the city centers and the
shopping centers are
coming back really strong this year, so at
the moment we don't see that the cities
are losing out on our specialist markets, what they usually say is absolutely
right, especially after Corona and even
during Corona in the meantime
Markets always
work best, but we see that
at least in our case, there are frequencies in
the city centers and also in the
shopping centers.
People walk in and how many people
buy, of course, yes and but there
is still vacancy but the
feeling that that  in Hamburg I was there
myself but when I walk
down Mönckebergstrasse it's
amazing because all of a sudden there are
n't any shops that aren't populated. I
think that we are also a destination for many customers.
You have to say that
Deichmann simply stands for an
incredibly competent range of
fashionable, high-quality items  Good inexpensive ones, there
aren't maybe not so
maybe alternatives in this respect so
we still don't feel that
our stores were somehow in
great decline
competitors that you might
say Reno the company was called deliciously
filed for bankruptcy who wants to now that would
be my signal man  That has to
have an impact on you too and then
I have to worry
too, but it hasn't stretched you in any way,
so
if you look closely at where the
bankruptcies took place, that applies
to the textile
sector and to the school sector
Reno Salamander clauser and so on in the
textile sector Galeria Kaufhof
Gerry Weber Esprit also B&C that was almost
always in the middle price range and it was
often also in
companies that didn't
have a very clear profile and where of
course the
series of crises
were really too much at some point  I mean what
the fashion retail sector has
experienced in the last few years has
not happened since the war.
First of all we had Corona, which in
itself was almost a threat to the existence of many due to the closure,
then came
the supply chain disruption that was
Sometimes it came way too late for me.
Seasons were missed, then there was
enormous overstocking and now
this inflation came and it is precisely
inflation that leads people
to become even more price-oriented. You
buy, you take a
closer look and you really want that
best price-performance ratio
We benefit from this to a certain extent. We can
also see that in the food trade,
own brands are gaining popularity and the
discounters are generally allowed to do more again.
Grocery trade is a
movement that doesn't feel the price
middle, of course, more strongly than we do,
perhaps just briefly
In addition, we still see that the
stationary business is our strong
pillar but of course we
also want to invest in online indexes and also
grow online. We actually only
went live with our new channel platform
in the Czech Republic and Slovakia two weeks ago  We
had a background and old
legacy system that we developed to a certain extent
ourselves and at
some point we came to the conclusion that we would
no longer be able to move this system
cost-efficiently and in the necessary time
in the future, which is why we have
a partnership with about  you
are now on the scale platform and
have actually
managed to build a completely
new online shop from scratch within six months.
I think 11 or 12
different online shops or so, we
have a total of more than 40 online shops in the group
and they will
all be transferred to the Scale platform in the coming years
but you understand
or various snipes that is
onigo
my shoes and these are all
different concepts that we will
modernize step by step together with scale and we believe
that if we go to
We have, let's say, set up the platform cleanly,
we are actually very well equipped
and in the end we can operate the business model
that will lead to success and
that is omni channel, that is the
networking of the stationary business with the
online business, that is, the two channels
not act separately from each other
but rather that you can offer positive effects such
as click collect as with
online return in store to
the customer and in the
end it is a service that many pure
players cannot do everything,
so to speak you can then experience perfect click and collect
with you  collect
already works in all Deichmann
countries and we will use the platform over
the next few years.
I think I have researched
that somehow around 10% of the current
online share is offline,
so I'm glad that my
son said that now
Of course, we also take the online business
extremely seriously and for us the
ten percent is around 800 million,
so we make 800 million in online
sales, which is not a very small
size and um and we are growing online, we are
growing significantly more online this year
against the market the market
still has problems that you probably
know and I'm glad we're gaining
market share and we have huge
potential and
generally your biggest yes if you
film it like that which company is where
it is in total  The thing that looks the most,
I think there isn't one big competitor, there
are various
companies that we take very, very seriously. On
the one hand, Amazon actually has
sales
of shoes in Germany that are probably
around a billion euros, then
they are only in Germany  In Germany
I think two billion or something like that is
already too big Amazon in
Germany has become half as big as you,
okay right then there are
of course the vertical textile providers
H&M Zara who have discovered shoes as a
really very exciting accessory
and especially online
also have a very wide range
We also take driving and Decathlon very, very
seriously because we have of course increased our share of sports
in the last few years
and Decathlon is a
really very strong company in sports and in terms of price
People bought a lot of shoes,
so in Germany the number is like this,
why and four pairs four pairs okay, that
means we probably
even have it with you, which would have to be 50 € 40
wrong
a little more now than 50 €,
no, that's the kind of thing  who
like to
simply our average price our
average price is around 25
euros
[music]
and what role does Zander
Zalando play, of course, it's
quite clear that
we have customers who
basically correspond to the demographic
cross-section of the population
and of course there are  There are a lot of customers
who also buy from us at Zalando
and from Zalando it's very clear that
Zalando is also one of our
competitors, most of whom are
priced above us, but
our customers
Some of our customers also buy from
Zalando, no question and in this respect
we take them very seriously  seriously and we
do it well when it was founded
because I mean I mean that it was built that way
in order to then
sell it, that's how Rocket Internet
wanted to
sell it quickly and I suspect almost back then there
was a bit of speculation
Deichmann and so on will
always strike, or maybe Otto or
Deichmann too, but remember,
of course,
we were actually online a
little earlier, we
opened the first online shop but
then very quickly realized
that if you finance conventionally
in that sense  Spend what you
earn so that an omni
channel model is certainly the right thing,
the Zalando model is based on the
principle of hope, you basically
financed yourself through the stock market and the rising stock market prices, that did
n't exist until then and it
was  Of course,
very low interest rates were also possible today. Today
it would certainly be a bit more
difficult, I have to say, but
Zalando has now
consolidated its position
We
've always been very, very focused
on what we do and
our goal was to
just let it grow further
internationally and then since 2011
Snipes still hasn't
spoken at all, I'm just
waiting to go back because I think
that  Well, I imagine at least
that you sleep restlessly from time to time
and ask yourself whether I can implement my
philosophy of 100% family and here
you can see that
they now also have almost
10 billion in sales
The scale has grown um very
quickly
you don't worry about whether that
might not have been the right way
because they went there and
financed it differently, for example I
think last year, which was our record,
showed us that
at least we didn't go our way  We were completely wrong
and I think we see Zalando
as someone that we take very, very seriously
but also as someone from whom
we naturally learn what makes
sense for us. I think the
topic of how do you use customer data and how do
you control accordingly, for
example  its marketing is good according to
this customer data, that's something
that we saw at Zalando, that
we saw very strongly with about User
and we're now adapting that to
a certain extent into our
own marketing management, but I
think the core of our business model is
good shoes with a  good quality at the
best possible price I think this
promise alone is
currently so good and so attractive for the customer
that at least we don't have to
make a fundamental change in strategy now,
but it has already happened so I'm
observing yes and even if he
himself is a very small bespoke entrepreneur
and thinks  always so okay, how long can
you do it on your own, so to speak, and
so on, and if he himself is impressed by it
and I just want to understand
how is that possible, so to speak, against all of them?
Amazon is also incredibly
well financed, of course, it is also listed on the stock exchange.
There are other options  I
then have to say against existing and always
do everything from a cash flow. I've
now seen that it somehow makes
around 500 million West is planned
for the group this year, that's
a lot of money but you have
now formulated it negatively and
left billions of potential lying around  who have now
collected Zalando Amazon that
could have been the ones who have been with
Zalando for ten years or those who
have Amazon that would have
been much bigger in the end, the Deichmann could
have had a small piece of the larger customer, yes but  You have to
see the differences in positioning. Zalando is clearly
positioned above us and Zalando
sells most of the
third-party brands. Deichmann is still very,
very strongly driven by its own brands.
That's our particular strength through
verticalization, we really determine
our collection ourselves, that's it  At
Zalando it's not the case how many percent,
so of course we now have
a huge share of sports brands,
I thought that has grown enormously
but our own share is probably
still over 70%,
the epitome of Deichmann is already um
fashionably up to date but really
unbeatable in terms of price and
You won't find anything like that at Zalando and
only to a limited extent at Amazon.
They've also concentrated on higher price ranges
because the
inexpensive online store isn't entirely
realistic either. You have to say
which brands generally play what role, so
I don't want to see many of them you
said  You have the
European license for it, so to speak. I know from
other conversations with sneaker store operators, so to speak, that being
able to connect the most modern Nike shoes and Adidas shoes is
absolutely relevant to you.
I think the Deichmann concept can be
described relatively well with the best
Price-performance ratio in the
low price range and I think
brands are an incredibly important
part of our strategy because you
can communicate quality to customers very, very well. So for
years we had the slogan branded shoes
so cheap, I think if you were to test it today it
would always be  is still
relatively well known and that's exactly
why we have had
Adidas and Puma shoes in
our range since the 80s. My
father has just said that in the
beginning of the 2000s we
added Elephants and Gallus
where we really did again  We have
been able to demonstrably acquire new customers who
have not previously come to our stores and I think that is why
we are taking our partner properties
to big brands, especially in the
sports sector. Nike
wanted to get what
they
have defined for the family football channel as part of the segment
Of course, we have
another channel with Snipes where
we get different shoes, but I
think that's what makes us as a group
such an interesting partner
for the brands that they actually have a dealer partner for
each customer group for each segment,
so if
They don't take the goods away from you so quickly at Nike
because they know,
man, they're the same people who
have Snipes and they do
n't have very few branches now, so on the
contrary, Nike and Adidas have
public effective nouns that they're
actually different from  We want to separate from the large number of
retailers and at the same time
we know that we
will definitely be one of the retailers who will continue to
find true friends in the future. It
is critical but not living now is
important because that means the
latest Nike is a spectator with you  At
Deichmann not at Snipes it is
definitely more important than at I
am but of course at
Deichmann we also want to offer current goods for our
customers but
the chick development so that Nike
said we would rather
sell directly ourselves that doesn't
worry you either no  Actually not, we are one
of Nike Adidas Puma's largest customers worldwide
and since the channel we
use is in the family footwork channel that
is not the preferred one of Nike
and all that for DTC
we need partners like us and
we can do it worldwide  the
very largest and that's why it's
excellent for collaboration, we get
a smoot deal with
such brands, we sometimes have our
own marketing campaigns with
testimonists of the brands that are only managed for us,
so it's an
excellent collaboration and as one
said  Nike is planning to
do business with fewer companies again
and fortunately we are one
of these leaders, so
more competitors arise for us to
meet in person. My father
always met me. I met Marc Barker
once. I was once in his office. That
's it  currently that was the
previous SEO who still
plays an important role who
led Nike very successfully for many years. They
were designers by training
and for me he was also a bit of
the reason because Nike
has this incredible creativity  and
this permanent innovative power that
really makes you wonder
how can this be related to the Snipes campaign?
I mean, you've
somehow experienced many campaigns or even
done them yourself, Snipes was the biggest.
No, you can't say that.
First of all, I'm in front of everyone
Things also for organic expansion
through what I said before,
after 92 after this success in Austria,
we
grew organically everywhere in Eastern Europe, Central Europe, Southern Europe and
founded our own companies and
rolled out our own chains. That was great, but we
just realized at the end of the 2010s
There is a market trend
that we cannot
adequately cover with Deichmann and that is this
sneaker. The sneaker business
became bigger and bigger and there were
also price ranges that could
no longer be
covered by Deichmann and that was the reason for
us  I looked around
if there was anyone who did it, who did it
well and who could you bet on to
play with it and then I
looked at different chains in Germany and ended up with Snipes, I
thought it was really good, I thought it was great, I thought
the premise was great
At that time, great Snipes had 35 stores in Germany,
two in Austria, which was still a
manageable unit and therefore
it wasn't a huge
acquisition financially very worthwhile, but
it has developed incredibly well.
We now have
700 stores and around 2
billion in sales this year  do with Snipes,
however, we have acquired very heavily,
especially in the last two
years, we have the USA, we have
bought three chains in the USA and there was a
very, very large acquisition there Jimmy
Test, we have also acquired in Europe
in Poland and Croatia and yes  We are
now number three in the world of
these
sneakery Sports UK but it is now
really clearly the second mainstay
for us in the group of companies
currently your topic
I am the managing director of our company,
I do
n't think I said that at the beginning and that's why
I'm currently spending  I also spent a
lot of time in Cologne together with Sven
because the business
wants to progress, the story is always
separate
and I don't have to be afraid to pay
to go to the USA because
it's a different market
and it's incredibly big and incredibly expensive
and there too  Again, if you attack with your own
resources then the USA is
already a braver move. I think especially for
Snipes it is actually the
sensible next step because we are
convinced that Snipes is a concept
that really has global potential
that Snipes ultimately sells
big brands Adidas Nike Puma Jordan
that are relevant not only in Europe
but especially in the
USA, where many of these brands come from
and I think that shows that we
can adapt very well to the respective strategy requirements, some of
which grow organically if necessary
But can we also, um, say,
grow organically and that hasn't really helped us so far. The
classic Deichmann business is also
pretty big in the USA, so that's it
now, insofar as the market is
already known to you, absolutely, so I said that
before, my father already had it in 1984
Bought a small chain in the USA record juice
but they had 16 LANs and that's
difficult today we have around 500
countries and it's really become a great
business it corresponds to
Deichmann which doesn't mean Deichmann and
the range is different the
American market is yes  really completely
different, the brands are even
more important and the sports cars
are even more important than here and
but otherwise the principle is very
similar. We also want to
offer great shoes, great brands there but at
the lowest possible price and that's what
got us there  very successfully
found your vertical purchasing which
is now
also done for Snipes or or for the USA
so that means you then buy centrally
in China all that you go back to
Germany so Snipes had completely
own purchasing and there is little
overlap because Snipes range
It's completely different, so very, very young, very,
very pointed. Above all,
the brand share is much, much larger.
Snipes really has to have these iconic
models from Nike, Adidas, Puma and so
on. There is also a
private car program that
is particularly important in the textile sector  but
that's very, very independent because it's
right at Deichmann, not too far okay,
at least I saved this
legendary fashion brand that I think
without without without that you can definitely say
make brands or or also say
make suppliers big or or in case of
doubt so that  The survival is burning
that the great strength of Snipes is to take brands
that are, let's say, deeply anchored in the uber urban
hip hop street culture,
small and then
make them big and there is no the best
example of where we were recently without a
football collection  launched that
made great sales straight away because some brands were afraid
of the classic Deichmann
and said that it was
too mainstream for me and that I didn't want to go
in there because that would mean that they
came across as too cheap or something like that, so there's a
negative there too  Feedback from
brand partners So in the last few years there has
been more and more support, I have to
say because Deichmann has changed
enormously in the last 20 years.
As I said, we have become a lot more
lifestyle-oriented if you
look at our stores today and also our
online shop  We come across as very, very modern
and look fashionably modern, the
colors, the lighting in the stores,
everything has changed enormously and
that's why there are much, much less
reservations. Of course, the
price is still
limited somewhere upwards, I'll say over
100 now  € want to make it a bit
difficult for us,
so over €100, that's
usually the case, but as I said, it's not
necessary, the volume under €100 is huge
and we still have further
growth potential there, but
more and more brands haven't become  only in the
sports sector we will now also do additional work from
the street sector
such as Rika we are also talking
about Bugatti and similar brands and
sports sector as I said Adidas Nike Puma
Asics
helps me then we still have balance
so the whole program what is
now  at Deichmann yours, so to speak,
probably not sports shoes, I
would think so because I always do,
but that's not the case, it's just not
that of the people in Germany,
at least not so what what with the
most bought
so you have to pay a little attention to the
season now  In the summer when
the temperatures are so high then
of course the classic
sandal plays a huge role, it's
inexpensive, it's the last one for 24 euros,
it's suddenly the
strongest shoe in huge
numbers,
it's very very weather-driven, which is
also the reason why my
Father and I can never be completely relaxed and
just look at the weather report.
We need very good weather in the summer.
We need cold weather in the winter
because otherwise the seasonal products
that my father was talking about
simply don't sell, so
that always sent a certain amount
means the guy wants to be sure that's
actually it's a minority the
majority looks at what kind of boots do I need
but as I said in April
it looks different every April the
sneakers are suddenly incredibly important
we did a campaign because
sneakers are all over our shop windows  were
only full of white sneakers and
it can happen that an Adidas
or Nike sneaker suddenly
becomes the strongest for a few weeks,
that's it, so to speak, it
really depends on the time of year are you
or are you on them every day
Look at the numbers every day, sales and
100 percent and then you'll see,
okay, now it's somehow
warmed up for the first time in the year, it's
always like that, as they say,
we're as dependent on the weather as the
farmers are  In general for the
fashion trade, this also applies to the
textile industry. Many people don't even know this, but
most customers actually
only buy when the need
arises and not in stock. It's
actually a bit irrational because
if you were to buy something earlier then
the stores would  still teachers then
of course all sizes are there and then it's
more relaxed shopping but it's
just not like that, especially in the last few
weeks when temperatures were around 30
degrees, our suffering was
really very well attended and they
really put out huge partner numbers  At the end you condensed all the branches and online
trading
into a sales figure,
so to speak, which was then implemented across all systems
that day and then
you look at it in the evening and somehow press
how loudly and then there
is this new line - it's only fair  the
next morning we'll work on it, that
's even earlier, but yes, I
think I can say the first
half hour of the day with you is
reserved for checking the implementation
and especially when the weather is as good
as it is at the moment, then you look  You
also pay attention to every single turnover from every
single company and
of course I do that too and okay that is and
then if something is wrong because there
is too much then you say that well and
if it is too little or less
likely compared to  Plan
then are correct like that and then you look
deeper into where are the
deviations or something like that just right and
then you call again and say
human sister go or something like that,
not every day now but I say
if a single company now has
several  There are no days so I implement them
than usual in other
companies then you ask
what's going on yes and what is
so often feedback yes so there is a
difference so there are very
different reasons sometimes
the holidays are different then there is
Holiday postponement
but then of course there are
also big weather differences within Europe,
so when it was so hot here,
which was still really cool in some parts of Eastern Europe
and also in Southern Europe, I can remember that
last week our
Italian managing director came because we,
um, that's it  actually the
management media had and he
told me in my case it's raining and 17
degrees is good then you know you can't
expect the same sales explosion
as we do
okay why is it actually the case that so
many very very globally successful
trading dynasties are coming so it  It's
already in Essen with Aldi, so it's possible
somehow there used to be Karstadt,
he has his backbone here
somehow the Thorsten Teller is there somehow now with Fressnapf also
somehow Krefeld is all a stone
ready to do
with the region
I can only speculate that the Ruhr area
naturally has a very high
population density. A lot of
people live in a small space and if something happens here,
not
all of the people here are overly wealthy
and that's why concepts are being
born here that are
geared towards price-performance
and with so many people who
can grow relatively quickly, I
think both
can be associated with this region
and that
also fits many concepts that emerged
and then suddenly grew up, you
actually say something,
maybe even  Success is also very
reserved, so I'm grateful for you
talking to me, but it's
not the norm for you
now, um, otherwise in communication you hear
about the classic
market-oriented communication with
Leni Klum and as I said now,
yes  Katzenberger and so on, but we hear
less from you than the family knows,
so yes, we don't take ourselves too
seriously, we don't have to
go to the press every day, so you could
perhaps say we're a
little more modest and we want
our time  to really do as
much good as possible for the customer
and also for the foundation and
our social aid organizations but yes we do
n't have to be in the press all the time, that's what I
just said so you get
involved and you can
read a little more about it than the
earthquake in Syria  were and a
million donations and so on but you
still don't have to worry about the fact
that at the end it's a shoe trade as the
operator is already a very profitable
business,
you're right that
we really earned these 8 billion on our
own
are not
on the stock exchange, we don't have huge
bank loans and so for
our development it's quite
healthy, yes
invested, they
logically come from a
cashflower but
you can so there is also one like that there is
also one like that  Maxim there is no payout for you afterwards,
that's the advantage we are a
very small family and we do
n't have any extremely expensive hobbies
[laughter]
we like to go to the mountains, we
like to go skiing, we like to go on ski tours or
go on long hikes, but we do
n't have any luxury yacht or anything
20 waves who knows where and yes the
family's need for money is
now we don't live in a
monastery so to speak but it's not that
the need is so great that it
probably doesn't affect anyone,
so we don't have to pay it out
and what I also go through  History
runs through you all, let's say
the church of its theology, you
may have also studied with your father,
I think, too, um, that's something that's also
happening,
in any case, you've just
hinted at it a bit, that's
actually been mine since my great-grandfather
Great-grandfather went
to Jewish
acquaintances on the Kristallnacht pogrom night because he
also had an obligation to them
because Christianity and Jews are of course
connected to a certain extent. The
whole thing continued through
my grandfather, who
actually started our charitable
work at the end of the 70s  back then in India it
stood at some point when he was invited to India
in front of 500 lepers
and that touched him so much that he now
said I now have two options:
either I run away and never come
back or I stay here and help
and he has  then at the end
the sentence was actually very strongly influenced God will
not ask me how many shoes I bought in the
end, but whether I lived like a
good person like a good Christian
and I think he passed that on to you
and you passed it on to me
because of that  We
also feel very connected to Christian values ​​and the Christian view of humanity. Yes,
you have a lot of discussions with other
entrepreneurs from dynasty
family businesses in Germany. There
is an exchange if now
the Viessmanns in the end, we have
n't sold most of their business,
it's you  You know each other or
observe each other,
no, we know a lot of
family business owners, of course, there are
always meetings and
exchanges, of course, but yes, I'm
not one who
takes part in such meetings very often,
but I do have a certain
number of family business owners with me  It
's the same for me with whom I always exchange ideas. I think especially in
the new generation people are a
bit more open, so
of course we don't talk about
any business secrets, but
we do talk about similar
challenges and
somehow through WhatsApp etc  you're
actually always very close to it
when you need someone to talk to, what
's the ambition, so where does
the ambition come from? I mean,
with you it was simply the wish that I wanted to
get the most out of my economic creative time as possible
or or what do you eat?  where it never
says we want
to reach a certain number or we want to
become the biggest, that was never the
deciding factor, but we have already
said we want the company
to develop healthily and my biggest
goal is to hand the company over to the
next generation in a healthy and successful way,
we have this long
Horizon but health is also where
growth is part of it, growth is part of it and
that applies to quantity but
also to quality and the demands have
just become greater, especially due to the
online dimension, the complexity of the
business model has grown significantly and um
now you also need other
profiles  Let's say the
people we need now have
completely different ones, must have different skills
or have additional skills.
Business is technologically
very different today, it used to be and my
son has just described that it is
important that you are in the right
places  Now we've recruited and we've
just
done a really great job with Alexander Berlin, he
really knows the online business
inside out and has achieved some groundbreaking things at about you
and with him, if
we push digitalization here even
further,
that this one  Ambition and
this motivation to build a company in the
form that you have now managed
or are planning to do, with a bit of
a Protestant work ethic
behind it, so there is also
faith or something that
drives you a little bit, it is very well
prepared
In fact, to a certain extent we
have, we have already
said it, of course economic
ambition and let's say sustainable
profitable growth is a driving force for us,
but I think you would also
say that
in the end it is also about what
we do with the profits
can do a good thing from the company, which is why
you spend a lot of
your time on our foundation's work, which is why
we regularly visit
the projects we support to
see how the money actually goes to the
people who need our help
But it's also partly
local here, so we actually have
a project in Dortmund that we've been
supporting for a long time, Stern im
Norden, and it's really about children
who,
in the worst case scenario, end up on the streets half an hour's drive away from us
know exactly what a
professional future has, run the risk of, let's
say, slipping into a difficult
situation and
we get these children off the street, help them
with their homework, spend time
with them, play with him
and thereby give him a completely different
perspective and I think that's it  In the
end, that's probably what
motivates us the most when we
visit projects like this and see
what kind of gratitude
we sometimes receive. Bad, but
Philippus is of course right. Let me
briefly explain the company's mission statement
and then maybe it will make it
even clearer  I put the
corporate mission statement that my father and
my grandfather always
exemplified in
written form and it has
the heading "Company had to
serve people" and for us that
specifically means that companies
must have even deeper goals and a deeper meaning than one  In order
to make sales and profit, ultimately it has to
benefit people and we look
at this triad first of all to the
customer. I want to say that is still somewhat normal,
but for us it is really
about offering a good product for our customers
in all the
dimensions that are important today  are and
at the best possible price and you
have to say that where we are we have
always contributed to
sensible shoes
remaining affordable and that in this respect we
have always really contributed to the democratization of fashion - that is
important to us and so are other people
the people who don't
have huge wallets should have the
opportunity to get sensible shoes
that is the first the second
is the company should serve the employee
we want our
employees to be taken seriously as people
they are not just a
cost factor or  some little
cog in the wheel, no, they are
people who we
want to treat as such. Of course, we have to
work hard, otherwise we ca
n't be successful.
Our per capita sales performance is
certainly the highest in the industry, but
the relationships between our superiors
should be good  We don't just want to focus on performance,
we
also want to support people when they
have problems, when they have worries,
when they have needs. The whole thing has a
financial material dimension
Employees and indebted people get into trouble,
be it due to a serious illness
due to an accident or even a
natural disaster, then our
relief fund helps very unbureaucratically
and quickly, especially in the case of natural disasters
like the hair flooding that is happening now, which
is sometimes really very,
very helpful for people. We
have one  Company pension that really
supports people in old age at the expense of the company. We do
a lot for the health
of our employees, offer a
variety of options to
really improve their health and
a lot more big celebrations and festivals, as
I said this afternoon we have
almost 2000  The employees get together in Weeze
and have a great
party, a bit of a professional part, but
then there is a concert and we
also want to thank the people because
this year in particular the work in
the countries was very, very hard because there
were large stocks due to Corona
The third thing is that the company is supposed to
serve people who are really in great
need because the poorest of the poor in
Germany but also internationally and
we have had very, very large social
projects for many years in India today
more in Africa
Tanzania now  Will it still be about Madagascar,
there is a work that we
now want to push forward,
Darwin Greece refugee work
but also here, as one said to his son, there
are absolute social hotspots here in the area around Essen
Duisburg,
millions of 100 million flow into him every year
or out of
20 million it is so we
spent around 15 million on these areas for many years. In
the Corona period it has become a little less
because many activities
could not take place, but if you
ask the environment about the motivation for
further growth it is  It is clear that if
the company continues to grow and continues to be
successful, then this work can
become even bigger and expanded
and of course that also plays
a role but in general it is a
motivation for this for the
entrepreneurial activity and also for
growth that we really do
Wanting to do good for people in this triad, the
customers, the employees and people in
need, that's the deeper motivation,
so there's enough money now and there
was enough success, but there's a
deeper meaning that we see and that
motivates the two of us  and of course that
also means that there are even more
possibilities then there really is a
need in the world a very small bit of
a cylinder. I somehow also
read the legend before preparing and
wanted to ask if it was okay whether
you or you or wrote about the opportunity
actually reads the Bible every day,
that's true, that's actually
not always true for as long as I would like
because it's really hard for me to get up,
but
I try
to read a biblical word for a short time in the morning
and think about it for a moment
and with that  Going into the day
so the others do some kind of
program or something else is fully
implemented again, yes, that's
actually the case
with you too, yes,
you also took over, yes, that's how it is
in the summer. I also think it's important and
interesting how we looked at the topic of
sustainability  Well, I think that's
also a topic that concerns us and that we have to deal with
right now. I mean,
millions of pairs of shoes are
obviously being produced and not all of them are
bought. What
are the topics? I would say that we have made the topic of sustainability a top priority, yes  Yes, it is clear that the topic
also plays a huge role for us and I would
say it is not a new topic for us,
especially social sustainability
has always played a huge role for us
and for us sustainability is
really what
we do for people
and in the service of the people
and in this respect,
the commitment in the social charitable
sector, as I mentioned earlier,
in the area of ​​education, in the
area of ​​medical care, in the
area of ​​social-educational
offers, is a very
important contribution for us to sustainability to
social sustainability  We have been delivering
with full conviction for many years,
sustainably and coldly, of course this
also takes place directly in the company and it is a
requirement. We addressed the
topic of social and ecological
sustainability
many years ago
with our coat of conduct.
We have
drawn up a code of conduct that
follows the  Criteria of the ILO of the
International Label Organization of the UN
organization have been defined that
define social and ecological minimum standards and we make these standards
a prerequisite for cooperation
with our supplier partners
around the world. This Code of Connect is
checked by independent
testing institutes. We are a member of the
BSCI amphoria initiative  and
testing institutes such as TÜV Süd and
various others
regularly check our supplier partners
and determine whether the conditions are as
they should be and if
not then this is reported to us and we
can then write and
remedy the situation. That is a small basis  has been around for
many, many years,
but sustainability of course continues today. We are
particularly concerned with the topic of climate, carbon footprint and of course
the topic of the circular economy, not
least of all
the
legislative proposals of the federal government and
the EU Commission that encourage us to do so
So we're
working intensively on this, the departments in the
company that handle this have
grown enormously and there are a lot of
things going on. I don't know how
far I should get out of it when it
comes to the CO2 issue
As far as we influence the company to switch
strongly to green electricity if
we try to
use renewable energies even more in the buildings
via solar panels
my main and you think okay there
is
not a sneaker for you but
the way of recycling the sneaker in
the fashion industry  is that the goods
as such are not all
sold and then what happens so that
you have to move with my head in it now,
yes absolutely
you are now talking about the topic of
circular economy which will of course
play a very big role
On the
one hand, we have individual
pilot products that I don't
want to make so important where recycled
materials are already used,
grease bottle material and so on, but
that's not a large number and it's also
not recycling in the classic sense.
We're working on the topic with
various institutes at the
Fraunhofer Institute  also to do with others
it is not so trivial with schools
it is much more
difficult than with textiles a shoe
consists of over 30 components
sometimes up to 50 60 components and
I can simply shred them without
further ado and then
reuse the components  It does
n't work that way and the most difficult thing is
to separate the individual components from each other
so that we can reuse them, so to speak,
and we're now
researching errors, and Fraunhofer, for example, we're
doing that with them.
You have to imagine that with a
shoe it's very difficult  That's why for
the days properties to bring the sole and the
shaft together as tightly as possible
you don't want the sole to
come off but for
recyclability or for
the circular economy exactly the
opposite is important all components
have to come off as easily as possible
so that it somehow works and  This
also applies to the outer material, many of our
schools are made of high-quality
synthetics, these are
coated textiles with polyrattan
coated textiles,
then polish them and get them off
again
But it's
in its infancy, it's actually
not that trivial, but we're on it, we
're doing a lot, but you just have to see that with such a complex production,
no one thinks about it,
it's so much more difficult than with the T-shirt and  where does it
currently come from so when where does
the goods currently come from
so you know what is now being
sold how are we actually piloting
a return box in our
branches for the first time in the coming weeks so it's not live yet
it will be going soon  live but
we want to take a very small look at
what kind of shoes we actually get
back and what can we
do with these shoes afterwards, so to speak, because I think my father
just said we take the topic very, very
seriously and that's it now
In fact, a large proportion of the
shoes worn
are not disposed of properly but
simply end up in the rocks or, in the
worst case, are even burned
and that is where we would of course like to
be the largest part of the solution and
not no factories where the school
then burns or  Something like that, no, that's what
you get from the service provider who
then takes the unsold goods back,
so we try to market the goods that
are basically in our stock as best as possible
and actually as
many as possible through our own
stores  to turn it out and everything that we
have once sold,
of course we can only somehow do so by sticking it on
and communicating with the customer to ensure
that the goods are as skilled as possible.
No, that is not a relevant part, so
we sell everything,
nothing is scrapped in any way
or sent to the third world  With
classics it's like that, so if you
see a collection from
a larger fashion brand then there's something that is
n't sold then I'm
not an expert but there is already a relevant amount
of goods that are then returned
or simply not sold at all
Part sold in the company's own
sales channels until it is gone,
it will be reduced for as long as it is
okay, so it's your turn and
that but he has the
very moving sneaker of this
research where they then looked at how the
cycle of a sneaker works
and um there was  The results weren't that
pleasing, that's true, that's true,
but that's why we're trying to
do it differently, what do
you have planned in general? I mean,
it's already
planned, I think you've already
said that he's Samuel the company  I
think it's fair to say that
at the moment I'm concentrating 100% from the
heart. It's a really
exciting company that I really
enjoy and I can
do it for a good five days a week
Sometimes it can take more than 5 days and I
have to be honest and say that I am
very grateful at the moment that
my father is still in the company and
that we can work so closely together.
We have our offices directly opposite each other. I am at mine 23 times a day
Father in the office My father is
in my office two three times a day and I
can learn an incredible amount from him. He
has been with the company for 34 years. He
knows the company better than anyone
else and probably recognizes the position
I am in better
than anyone else  no one else, that's why I'm
grateful for the trust I
get every day, that I'm now
actually allowed to move completely independently in my area,
gain my own experience, I'm also allowed to make mistakes and
hopefully we'll have exactly the
same picture in the good relationship
for a long time  carry on until hopefully
one day we come to the decision that
now is the time for me to
take over and but that if you do
n't know what will happen, that's still
open and but do you only have an
idea so if you say now I
'm obvious  will it then be your
professional life in the next few decades, we
are up to now, I'm 30 now, so then
you actually have a few more decades
ahead of you, it will
take place here, so of course it goes to your
head, what can you do with the 8 billion,
where will we be in 15  20 years
so it's like 20 billion what what
before so I think it's
clear that it has to be more the
next goal has to be ten billion
I think that hopefully
won't take too long and
we'll move on from there  have two
very strong concepts, but the family
football concept, to which I
would include Deichmann and Recklinghausen, and the
Snipes concept. I think with both of them
the growth story is far
from being told. We have two continents,
three continents in the inventory, and now we're
almost even there  not
take place Asia Africa South America and
I think if we manage to somehow find a basis there in the coming
years and decades
and continue to grow from there, I
think we still have a lot to do
you know that the
economic world from America from Europe is
generally worried about Germany a
bit as a standard or as a
country as a society if you have been
looking very intensively for many years, so to speak,
I mean Europe in general
has location disadvantages and it also has many
standard advantages but I say we
have to be careful that we do
n't make life too difficult for the economy.
Here, especially in Germany, we have
a fantastic welfare state that
is really good for people
and maintains social peace, but
the costs for this are
constantly growing and now have them  Above
all, we are concerned about the demographic problem -
the population will decline and we
have more and fewer
people who have to work for these social benefits
and we need
reform for both pension insurance
and long-term care insurance and
other things and our politicians are
often too close to that  Hesitantly, things have to
remain financeable otherwise the
meeting will simply be far too high for the companies and also the
tax burden,
so I would sometimes wish for a little
more willingness to reform, and
I think we will always
remain a highland country, no question about it,
but that's possible  only good if, on the
other hand, productivity
is correspondingly high and that's why
education is incredibly important and even
then more should be done
for both school and
university education and there would have to be a
much more pragmatic approach.
Sometimes it's a bit annoying
Dralism I think the federal government
only has limited options, but
you saw especially during Corona
how difficult it was for schools to teach
digitally, it was sometimes
embarrassing and it becomes clear that
more needs to be done. We also have to
see that we the people  Those who have come to us
integrate better, I think that's also
something we have to do better.
We don't have enough
skilled workers now. On the one hand,
I think we need more immigration,
qualified immigration, but also the
people who are here simply have to do
better  be integrated
that it has to be worth something to us so
there is a lot to do,
I think and yes
now comes the issue
of the
increase in energy prices, especially for
German industry, so that is
not entirely without we of course have to
for the protection of the climate and  There's
no question that CO2 is making it more expensive and when
you see that we can achieve lower CO2 emissions through
market economy methods,
but
at the same time we have to give industry
the chance
to somehow survive here and we have to bring these things
together and that's something I'm missing at the
moment  A little bit of the
really good concepts, so there's a
lot to do and we just have to
be careful that too many people don't
emigrate to America or somewhere else,
that's a bit of
my concern, but German
companies in particular have managed to do it again and again over
the years
to reinvent ourselves and have
created a lot of hidden champions,
so we have a great basis,
but we just have to make sure that we
can somehow retain these competitive advantages
I think I'm saying that
you're producing there and you can also
see the tension there at the moment or read about it,
he probably should, so that's
actually the world situation has become much more
uncertain than it used to be, that's
absolutely the case, the
tension
internationally, not just because of the war
but not a war but also have
increased and of course the world is watching
China and Taiwan with a spell and
many believe that a conflict
will arise and such a conflict would of course be
devastating for the whole world and for the European Union, which
is the trade exchange with China  huge
and the company is also very
closely linked to China,
so I'm very pleased that
Foreign Minister Blinken has now made this visit to China.
It now sounded a bit
more conciliatory. Nobody can win
in a war like this, so I hope  It's
always common sense what we do
as a company: we try to diversify even more,
we also go to
other countries and our partners, our
suppliers, our Chinese
also go to other countries in order to reduce the risk a
bit, so if of
course it's
good, then the trade immediately ends  I can't imagine
coming to Berlin from one day to the next,
but
of course I can. People are
always called upon
to protect themselves from something like that coming and
what are you doing? Yes, as I said,
we're in the process of diversifying,
we're going to other countries  Our
partners are going to other countries where
production is
basically being opened and you can then
postpone it if things get serious, but
it would definitely be associated with friction
and it wouldn't be without
problems
I imagine
the impact on you, yes, it will take some time
until you have a reallocation,
but I still can't
imagine that even if the
situation escalates,
trade between
Europe or Germany and China
will come to Berlin overnight, that is  That's not even
imaginable because the commitment
is so close, there is so much
exchange with China, that there
would be enormous upheaval here after then
look at what
Chinese companies are doing themselves, so
we're talking now, or I mean now skis
In Timo they are called a
larger trading platform, also for
fashion and for shoes,
which now deliver directly to the German market or
world market and also to the US market
and have a huge share there
and sometimes a pair of shoes
somehow costs €3.50 or so  So something like that in
your price segment or almost down um what
with it so we
look at rails very closely of
course it seemed to us that the model really shaped realtime fashion
um every day a few
thousand new models go on ski in life as well
as foodware and
at the same time that leads to that  that
a large part of the products that are
sold on rails have actually not
yet been produced at the time they are sold
because there are
such quick litans in production
that you can first see
how great the demand is for a
certain product produced in small quantities
Batch puts it online and depending on
what time it came in,
20,000 or 40,000 parts are
reproduced and then flown
to the USA or Europe within, say, three weeks
and the prices
are absolutely crazy - you
just said shoes three  up to four euros
in some cases, this huge selection in
combination with these low prices
is of course initially interesting for customers
and there is
a huge amount of marketing budget being
put into it. Germany
that can't be the case that you
can buy shoes for €300 here, that can be
out of our reach in the long term  From a point of view it will be very
difficult to be profitable and on the
other hand we have just
talked for a long time about sustainability. We are of course looking very
closely at what kind of products are currently
coming onto the market and we are looking at
whether these products comply with, let's say,
local pollutant regulations
So let's take a look at what's happening there on the
subject of copyright and French mentality
and there are
certainly some things where you
at least have to put question marks behind them as to
whether this can even exist in the long term in
regulated terms,
but not of course you can
look at the whole thing and you  I can see
if you can do something about it, but let me just
say something briefly. So what
we said applies
primarily to the textiles in shoes.
This speed is not possible.
Shoes simply have a much longer
song time. I have to order one
First of all, I have to make a shoe that
has a shape for the sole and I need a
last and so this very
quick delivery is
not possible
at all. As far as I know, this success is mainly due to the textiles,
so there are no strong schools
yet  At least it doesn't matter in
Europe.
We took a look at the products and
the quality
wouldn't be enough for us, I have to
say very clearly and in the USA you can
already tell, so if you see it in
Germany you haven't done it yet
so as far as I know it's not
something for you  Anyone ever have a topic in
textiles,
so we are partly in textiles,
at Snipes we have a not
inconsiderable proportion of textiles and we
also have extra sport then a decent proportion of
textiles but let's say at
Deichmann level we had always
maybe thought about it but have already  We've
seen that we're better off
concentrating and that we really
stick with shoes, the textile market
is extremely competitive, especially low,
and there are a lot of good players that
I don't think that we should get involved in that,
okay okay, so we've
talked for a long time  I have the feeling that there
would be more, maybe
we'll do an update at some point, maybe
if you don't do the
handover one day, who knows, can I
come again?
the openness or for conversation
in general, I know it's not usual for you,
thank you very much, it's nice that you
're here, thank you, thank you, Philipp